Hello!
We don’t know whether you’ve come here
because of ChatGPT or because you want to
know about research on chatbots in general
these days.
Then let us tell you how we came across the
idea of making this video.
A while ago, I was reading this incredible
paper from DeepMind proposing a new chatbot
called “Sparrow”.
While we were sitting on this paper and planning
the video,
here it was, the mighty ChatGPT from OpenAI
changed the landscape of the Internet!
(how exactly, you can see in plenty other
youtube videos.
We focus on the research, here.)
But disappointingly, ChatGPT did not come
with an extra paper release.
On the other hand, Sparrow from DeepMind has
a paper, but they don’t let us play with
the model.
And now that everybody’s interest is piqued
around chatbots, we really want to discuss
Sparrow, especially since it was trained very
much like ChatGPT, but with even more objectives,
because it can follow explicit rules and can
make google searches to provide evidence for
its answers.
Okay, great.
Since ChatGPT did not do such a good job at
telling me what to say to you in this video,
Ms. Coffee Bean will give her best shot at
explaining ChatGPT from OpenAI and Sparrow
from DeepMind.
But first, let’s thank Cohere for sponsoring
today’s video!
Since you are watching this video, we assume
you already heard about the incredible advancements
of natural language processing.
Maybe you thought of including the latest
and greatest large language models in your
applications?
Well, then Cohere is the right thing for you!
It lets you use extremely capable language
models to let them classify text for you or
let them generate documents.
Does this sound complicated?
Fear not!
Because it is not at all: Cohere’s specialty
is to take the finest transformer based models
like GPT and BERT and let them do the heavy
work for you under the hood.
All you need is to write these few lines of
code to start generating text; you don’t
even need machine learning skills to use Cohere.
Just install with `pip install cohere` and
you are ready to go in Python.
So, what are you waiting for, sign up to Cohere
and start exploring it.
They have a very generous free premium developer
tier, so no credits are needed.
Users bear no costs until they go to production.
You can sign up with this link, also posted
in the video description below.
Now back to our chatbots.
Let’s get a thing out of the way: How do
chatbots like ChatGPT work?
They are based on language models, which is
just a fancy neural network that can do autocomplete.
Language models predict next probable words
given previous words.
Even before the user starts conversing with
chatbots like Sparrow or ChatGPT, they already
have an input, the so-called prompt, which
is basically a description of the conversational
persona given by the programmers.
This prompt increases the probability that
the next words the language model will spit
out, are in line with this persona.
So, if here in the prompt we have the word
“helpful”, then most likely, the model
will predict next words that match this description
and will not start using swear words – as
easily.
Ok, so how does this language model converse?
After this input prompt, which is hidden from
you in ChatGPT’s interface, it is your turn
to ask it a question, then given your question
and the persona description, it delivers an
answer.
Then you say something again and it reads
the prompt, your first question, its answer,
your second question and based on this, it
continues to say likely words that come after
this whole history.
And this goes on and on, which each interaction
from your side and the model’s response,
you make the model’s input, longer and longer.
The “magic” thing about these large language
models behind ChatGPT, is that they are super
fancy autocompletes that can pick patterns.
For instance, if you prompt them with descriptions
and examples that tell them about an HTML
alternative, called HBML, they start to pick
up the pattern,
and the most likely words following your examples
are the correct solution to the things you
just entered.
This is called in-context few-shot learning.
In-context, because it is not like the model’s
parameters update through learning in the
classical sense of weight optimization, it
is just that the input already has a pattern
in it that elicits correct answers from the
model, making it seem like it has learned
something.
That the model itself does not update, becomes
clear when we see that this whole history
of conversation and all things the model “learned”
from you is gone when you or somebody else
opens another conversation with the chatbot,
the input is now gone and the model works
just with the prompt and not with the things
you had previously conversed with it, or other
people did.
In this new conversation, the history starts
anew, so it is not like the model learns anything
from past sessions of conversations or from
other users.
Now we maybe want to know how ChatGPT from
OpenAI works.
ChatGPT itself does not have a paper explaining
it, but it has a blog post.
Here we find out that it is a sibling of InstructGPT
and it was trained similarly to InstructGPT
which has a paper from which we find out that
it works very much like Sparrow from DeepMind.
And in this video, we would rather present
the Sparrow paper since it came later and
is a bit more comprehensive, you’ll see
why.
At the end of the video, we will highlight
the differences between Sparrow and InstructGPT,
so therefore as much as we know about ChatGPT
so far.
[Sparrow explained] So, Sparrow is DeepMind’s
version for a chatbot.
Interestingly, the Sparrow paper never uses
the word “chatbot” and maybe it has something
to do with the fact that for a long while,
it was out of fashion to use the term, since
research in chatbots was hyped starting with
Eliza in the 1960s and it failed to deliver
onto its promises.
So, research building chatbots, such as DeepMind
here with Sparrow, preferred to use a other
terms like “dialogue agent”, “dialogue
system” or “conversational AI”.
It is relieving to see that OpenAI makes the
word chatbot fashionable again by naming their
model “ChatGPT” and look, they even use
the word “chatbot” in their blog post
once!
We think it is a pity DeepMind did not release
Sparrow or at least gave access to users to
interact with the model, like OpenAI does
with ChatGPT, especially since we find the
Sparrow method, its motivation and paper really
cool.
Why did this team of researchers think about
building Sparrow?
Their motivation was that language models
when prompted to behave like chatbots tend
to say inappropriate things, including sexist,
or racist statements and tend to be opinionated.
The language model just doing its thing of
predicting next probable words to what was
just being said, does not have even the means
of knowing whether it is offending somebody.
So, the idea with Sparrow is,
what if we could define a set of rules and
finetune the language model to follow the
rules.
While this sounds easy, it is quite hard to
convince a language model to follow rules
and the author’s solution here involves
human feedback at a smaller scale about the
model following or breaking rules, then training
classifiers that will mimic human feedback
at larger scale and then fine-tuning the language
model with reinforcement learning to follow
the feedback of the classifiers.
And since the classifiers reflect the human
feedback and the human feedback tells us something
about the model following the rules or not,
we should have convinced the language model
to follow rules.
This seems complicated, how to do this more
exactly?
The authors build Sparrow by fine-tuning Chinchilla,
their 70 billion parameter language model
that already has great capabilities at producing
high quality text and solving natural language
understanding tasks.
To make it a chatbot, or “dialogue agent”,
the authors use this prompt to convince it
to take the conversational persona of a “highly
knowledgeable and intelligent AI assistant”,
give it its name (“Sparrow”) and describe
what the user should expect from it and also
an example conversation.
Now, following this prompt, a user can type
in a question or another conversation starter
and Chinchilla will take in the prompt, the
user’s question and then give the answer.
But Sparrow can do something more than just
converse, which is provide evidence for the
answers it gives.
To achieve this, the authors do a specific
update to Sparrow’s prompt:
we have two more participants in the conversation,
namely the Search Query and the Search results.
The “Search Query” is basically also a
Sparrow persona, where the language model
generates a search query based on what was
said in the conversation so far.
And the “Search Results” is basically
a call to Google Search and provides a short
preview and link to the result.
So now this whole thing containing the description
for Sparrow, example User inputs and Search
Queries and Search Results are the prompt
which Sparrow always has as input and generates
answers with.
Now we come to the part where the authors
make Sparrow also follow rules.
First, the authors come up with 23 rules.
The rules roughly cover 3 categories for making
Sparrow more helpful, correct and harmless.
Of course, this list is not exhaustive, as
the authors themselves admit.
One could (and should) come up with more rules
and apply the whole strategy we are describing
here on the additional rules.
Now, to make Sparrow follow these rules, the
authors let it talk without it knowing about
these rules and humans annotate how well it
does, on different aspects: they tell which
rules are violated, and whether it should
search the internet to provide evidence and
in case it provided evidence, whether it was
good.
Humans are also given an adversarial setting
where they try their best to break the model
and make it violate the rules.
Here, in a sense, the humans are encouraged
to get the worst from the model.
This is valuable training data for fine-tuning
Sparrow, since the new iteration of the model
should avoid the worst of the last iteration.
So this is the human annotation stage, where
humans give feedback on how Sparrow is performing.
Since Sparrow at this stage is just a Chinchilla
language model prompted for conversation,
it should not do that good.
Now, the authors take the human generated
annotations to train a neural network to classify
how probable it is for a human to like the
answer Sparrow produced.
They train another classifier to say whether
a response is likely to break a rule or not.
These classifiers are useful, because now
the authors can train Sparrow with them.
For each answer Sparrow produces during training,
a classifier can extremely quickly estimate
the human feedback for it.
Asking humans during training for so many
examples, would make training last forever.
So, the authors froze the last 64 layers of
Chinchilla and fine-tuned the last 16 layers
with reinforcement learning taking the output
scores of the classifiers, enforcing the model
to have low scores on rule violation and high
scores for the estimate of a human to appreciate
the answer.
For training, they used a dataset consisting
of questions and answers from the Explain
me Like I’m 5 dataset, also conversations
from the human annotators and the generations
of Sparrow’s last iteration, because why
not apply this strategy in more stages, until
Sparrow becomes better and better at following
rules and searching the Internet to provide
evidence?
During inference with the last iteration of
Sparrow, to get the best answer from the model,
the authors let Sparrow generate multiple
answers and give to the user the answer that
ranks best given the outputs of the classifiers.
Ok, how much better did Chinchilla get after
all this heavy lifting involving human annotation
and reinforcement learning to become Sparrow?
Humans say that Chinchilla delivers answers
that are plausible 61% of the time, while
Sparrow’s answers are plausible and supported
by evidence 78% of the time.
This is looks good.
Chinchilla breaks rules 20% of the time, while
Sparrow only 8% of the time.
But what I love about this Sparrow paper is
the extensive evaluation of the models.
Surprisingly, fine-tuning Chinchilla to become
Sparrow, reinforced some of the language model’s
stereotypes.
Just to give you one example, the scores of
Sparrow are worse on the Winogender dataset
measuring bias towards gender, than for the
baseline Chinchilla model.
Now that we know about Sparrow, let’s highlight
its differences to ChatGPT.
First, Sparrow was prompted and trained to
deliver evidence for its answers when needed,
by searching the Internet and providing the
user with the link.
ChatGPT cannot do that.
ChatGPT is also a prompted language model
based on GPT 3.5, it was also trained through
fine-tuning on conversations provided by humans.
So, humans rank the language model’s responses
and this data is used to train a classifier
modelling how a human would rank ChatGPT’s
answer, much like with Sparrow.
Fine-tuning with reinforcement learning uses
the information provided by the model for
estimating a human in the loop and therefore
trains to provide better answers.
But ChatGPT misses one very interesting component
that Sparrow has: Sparrow also had training
from a classifier trained on human annotation
telling it how well it can follow a set of
rules.
So, in a sense, ChatGPT is like Sparrow, but
without the capability of searching for evidence
and without rule following, which makes it
a bit underwhelming.
Hey, Ms. Coffee Bean, maybe Sparrow’s conception
was more far-sighted than ChatGPTs, but we
at least have access to ChatGPT and can play
with it.
Regarding Sparrow, we can only look at the
paper and dream to play with the model.
What a world!
We have models without detailed papers and
we have detailed papers without model releases.
Should we even start dreaming about model
weights and code releases?
We hope you enjoyed our overview about chatbots
these days and we hope to see you next time!
Okay, bye!